estás escogiendo globos de agua hay tres
opciones de color y dos opciones de
tamaño si escoges aleatoriamente el
color y el tamaño cuál de estas tablas
se puede usar para encontrar la
probabilidad de las soluciones cada
columna representa una solución
veamos tabla que está aquí dice mira
puedo elegir uno de los tres colores
verde naranja o amarillo y si escojo
verde puedo elegir entre verde y grande
o verde y pequeño por lo que esos son
los dos posibles tamaños para este color
ahora con el segundo color naranja tengo
dos posibles tamaños naranja grande o
naranja pequeño y para el tercer color
amarillo tengo dos posibles tamaños
amarillo grande o amarillo pequeño
esta tabla parece ser útil para
representar las probabilidades de una
solución estas son todas las posibles
soluciones que puedo obtener
si aleatoriamente elijo un color y un
tamaño si alguien me dice oye cuál es la
probabilidad de que cuando
aleatoriamente elijas un color y tamaño
te toque un globo naranja y grande
bueno pues naranja y grande es una de
estas posibles seis soluciones que se
encuentran aquí entonces esta tabla se
ve muy útil por lo que diré que la tabla
a definitivamente aplica veamos la tabla
b entonces puedo tener verde y grande y
veamos si este color tiene otro posible
tamaño porque para cada color deben de
haber dos tamaños posibles perder grande
y verde pequeño entonces el verde tiene
los dos posibles tamaños
para naranja tiene al grande y naranja
pequeño entonces para el naranja tiene
las dos opciones de tamaño amarilla
grande o amarilla pequeña entonces
parece ser que tiene todas las opciones
posibles como la tabla que está aquí
solamente que escritas en un orden
diferente entonces ésta se ve igualmente
legítima cuál es la probabilidad de que
tengas un globo naranja y grande pues
naranja y grande es una de seis posibles
soluciones entonces esta tabla también
aplica